les propos étaient totalement
inadmissible répétées et inadmissibles
et c'est le propos d'un d'un siècle
passé aujourd'hui rien ne peut justifier
cela est encore plus en france ou bien
entendu que les races n'existent pas
plus ici qu'ailleurs mais où nous avons
la capacité et ce sur quoi nous devrions
être arquebouté c'est la laïcité c'est
la capacité à vivre ensemble
je dis qu'il y a aujourd'hui des lignes
de conjonction entre la droite et
l'extrême droite qui sont très fortes
sur un certain nombre de sujets et
d'analystes sur notre pays que moi je
rejette ces analyses je les considère
comme totalement fausses